un jour de plus dans l'escaladé
meurtrière en prix sera lé la palestine
au coeur d'une deuxième semaine de
conflit de nouveaux raids israéliens ont
frappé la bande de gaza ce mercredi un
peu plus tôt devant la presse un haut
responsable militaire de l'état hébreu
indiqué que l'opportunité d'un cessez le
feu était actuellement à l'étude
un espoir rapidement nuancé par le
premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou qui n'entend pas revoir ses
positions et promet de venir à bout du
hamas si sa stratégie de dissuasion
n'aboutirait pas il n'y a que deux
façons d'y faire face
soit de les combattre et c'est toujours
une possibilité ouverte soit de les
dissuader et nous sommes actuellement
engagés dans la dissuasion mais je dois
dire que nous n'excluons rien nous
espérons pouvoir rétablir le calme nous
espérons pouvoir le faire rapidement
je tiens à dire que nous le faisons tout
en faisant de notre mieux pour éviter
les pertes civiles
nous n'avons pas cherché ce conflit en
plus de ces nouvelles menaces vers gaza
l'armée israélienne a annoncé ce
mercredi mener des tirs d'artillerie
vers le sud du liban en représailles
pour le lancement de 4 roquettes depuis
le territoire libanais en direction de
l'état hébreu dans la bande de gaza le
peuple compte ses morts au milieu des
bâtiments détruits tandis que les
hommages aux civils tués sous les
bombardements se multiplient
[Musique]
des centaines de bâtiments ont été
détruits à gaza et plus de 70 mille
palestiniens ont été déplacés après les
frappes israéliennes dans un discours
télévisé le président de l'autorité
palestinienne mahmoud abbas dénonçant un
terrorisme d'état de la part d'israël
nous persisterons à demander des comptes
à ceux qui ont commis ces crimes devant
la cour pénale internationale
nos efforts se concentrent sur l'arrêt
de l'agression israélienne contre notre
peuple à jérusalem dans la bande de gaza
et en cisjordanie
nous entrerons alors dans un processus
politique sérieux avec un médiateur
international qui conduira la fin de
l'occupation israélienne des terres
palestiniennes y compris jérusalem est
notre capitale sacré de jérusalem
de son côté l'europe espère jouer son
rôle de médiateur
ce jeudi le chef de la diplomatie
allemande se rendre à jérusalem et
ramallah aux états unis joe biden vient
de hausser le ton pour inciter à un
cessez le feu
son soutien à israël ayant fortement
divisé l'opinion